hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ich habe auf meinem Kanal hier
bereits zweimal quizzes gemacht die drei
Fanpages von mir auf kahoot erstellt
haben von daher machen
und Robin sind auch wieder mit am Start
Intelligenz Allergiker Quiz hi
eins los geht's erste frage ich
muss jetzt den
[Musik]
also wir haben die Auswahl ich bin eine
Taube ich hasse euch ich habe in Pool
gefurzt oder ich reite Sandra ich würde
mal sagen ich habe in den Pool gefurzt
[Musik]
heute mit Ansage alles richtig wahr oder
falsch das ist wahr ich schwöre euch
heute
mach dir nichts draus große Taten warten
auf dich schönes Bild auch hier an der
Stelle von mir was ist die Mehrzahl von
Globus ich glaube
ich glaube Globi
[Musik]
Globen wie viele Salzstangen beinhaltet
eine Packung im Durchschnitt
das bin ich
ich würde sagen eine Packung Salzstangen
beinhaltet 175 vielmehr können das nicht
sein
112 da kriegt man wenigstens was für
sein Geld wie viele Minuten Verspätung
haben Züge der Deutschen Bahn im
Durchschnitt boah starkes Bild auch
jeder da muss man tatsächlich sagen ich
habe dafür vollstes Verständnis wenn die
Bahn mal Verspätung hat weil ein Einzug
kann nicht zu früh sein ein Flugzeug
wenn er voll beladen ist wenn alle
Passagiere drin sind kannst du abheben
aber beim Zug gibt es immer diese Leute
die dann noch nachkommen oder kurz vor
knapp 30 Sekunden vor Abfahrt oder so
das heißt ein Zug kann nie früher
irgendwo ankommen oder überpünktlich
sein das geht nicht
Verständnis für ich würde sagen im
Durchschnitt 6 Minuten
ich liebe Bahnfahrer macht mir keiner
was vor mir Flex never gonna give you up
never gonna
let you
don't
t was habe ich jetzt das war richtig
gehabt aber wenn ich die anderen beiden
auch noch angekreuzt hätte ich mehr
Punkte bekommen wie lautet die Formel
für Fotosynthese
ey dieser Baum ne
was ist das überhaupt schon wieder für
eine Musik ich sag einfach dir weil ich
will jetzt die Musik aufhört
ich war noch nie gut in Chemie was ist
der Weltrekord im Bratwurst essen
innerhalb von 10 Minuten ey wie kommt
der denn auf diese
der Weltrekord im Bratwurst essen in 10
Minuten würde ich sagen boah 45 Grad
Würste
[Musik]
wie viele Weihnachtsbäume fangen in
Deutschland durchschnittlich in der
Weihnachtszeit Feuer okay
was die geringste Zahl ist 7000
7 nee wer kann das nicht sein
12000 Weihnachtsbäume fangen in
Deutschland nur in der Weihnachtszeit
Feuer
okay alle nicht schmücken letzte Frage
vom ersten der drei quittes wie heißen
die vier Teletubbies Tick Trick nee
tinky Pinky Winky dipsy lala Po
geh mal weg mit Foto Synthese das sind
die einzig wichtigen Dinge schauen wir
uns mal das Ranking an wer ist auf dem
dritten Platz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ist immer erst dieses Quiz gerade
war übrigens von Mona aka wird Punkt
Lords of Instagram also folgt dir gerne
und das nächste Quiz was wir jetzt
spielen ist das hier das Luca Quiz und
das ist von Luki unterstrich der
Unterstrich Lauch wie viele Merch Sachen
gibt es aktuellem luca-shop boah gar
nicht mal so viel ich würde sagen stabil
20 20 ich würde sagen 20
[Musik]
sehen sogar nur allerdings gibt es bis
morgen Abend noch bis zu 33% Rabatt im
luca-shop wegen des Black weekends von
daher schaut gerne mal vorbei
wann nahm Luca an der Wok WM teil boah
das war der 12.11 nee es wird doch
12.11.2022 stabiles Bild auch übrigens
ich dich jetzt mit Ansage alles richtig
wahr oder falsch Luca klaut gerne Witze
und tut so als wären es seine frech
das ist falsch das ist falsch ich habe
noch nie ein Witz von deiner Fanpage von
euch geklaut und bei mir in noch nie was
wollte Luca als Kind unbedingt haben ein
Spielzeugauto ein Gameboy ein Pferd oder
ein Handy ein Gameboy tatsächlich
habe ich da noch irgendwann bekommen wo
nehmt ihr diese Bilder von mir her
welches Video hat die meisten Aufrufe
auf dem Kanal laserlug aber ich glaube
das ist eine Katja reaction Interview
mit Domme nee ich hasse Siri er hat uns
bedroht oder boah ey es ist schwierig
die Katja Action ist nicht mit drin das
ist einfach falsch geschrieben
perfekt er hat uns bedroht war einfach
ein stinknormaler Vlog wo Kinder zu uns
ankamen und uns bedroht haben oder die
lustigsten Schüler von ich glaube eins
von dem oberen beiden aber ich dachte ja
sehr gut
so genau kenne ich meinen Channel dann
doch noch war oder falsch luca hat kein
Zeitgefühl und kommt immer zu spät das
ist auch falsch
kompletter Schwachsinn wie oft hat sich
Luca bisher mit dem E-Scooter gemault
jede Woche mindestens einmal zu oft
nicht zählbar 200 Mal und ein Bild von
mir wo ich in Rom damit dem ist wieder
rum fahre ich glaube es sind mehrere
Antworten richtig
[Musik]
dritt letzte Frage was war Lukas erstes
Handy ein Nokia 6300 ey wo ihr diesen
Krams auspackt ne besser ganz genau was
ist in Hamburg im La Villa Restaurant
gewesen im Hafen vorletzte Frage welches
Wort passt zu diesem Bild okay müssen
wir uns das Bild anschauen
oh
[Musik]
ich habe eine 3er Antwort Serie und die
wird auch jetzt nicht reichen meine
Damen und Herren was tut Luca in seinen
Videos sehr oft klatschen
furzen
[Musik]
gib mir den ersten wenn ich nicht der
Erste bin dann wie du direkt vorbei
nennt sie auf drei das ist ein richtige
genugtuum Mall of der 2 und Nummer eins
ich brauche gar nicht gucken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommen wir nun allerdings auch schon zum
letzten Quiz für heute was jedoch eine
kleine Besonderheit mit sich zieht das
ist nämlich dieses hier das ultimative
Dick und Doof Quiz und das wurde gemacht
von der lieben
con__loogie
wann wurde die erste Folge
veröffentlicht
welches Jahr 2019
[Musik]
was hattest du getippt auch erster
Achter ganz genau hat die
Ausbildungsbeginn das stinkt genauso
schlimm wie Lukas 14
[Musik]
Bilder
auf Instagram
[Musik]
was steht da Sushi Gucci
wer war zuletzt zu Gast bei Dick und
Doof
[Musik]
ich schwöre ihr seid so am Arsch ne was
tut Sandra während der Folgen sehr oft
rauchen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Bruder
alles richtig warum spielt Luca
Mundharmonika wegen der fragewunder der
kündigt so die Frage runter an er hat
seine eigenen Bett er möchte Mozart
Konkurrenz machen er spielt Sandra ein
Liebeslied vor die Frage oder an hey ich
schwöre jeder der unseren Podcast nicht
hört der weiß gar nicht worum es gerade
geht oder warum wir das witzig bin und
daher könnt ihr euch ja gerne die neue
Folge anhören
spotify.com/stick und doof wie viele
Folgen Dick und Doof gibt es insgesamt
wir müssen überlegen wir hatten 100
Folgen corona-folgen ja machen wir 324
komm nee
Sandras Traumjob ist dachdeckerin das
war oder falsch falsch ja
was ist ein Traumjob Erzieherin war das
ne wo kamen Sandra und Luca auf die Idee
ein Podcast zu starten im Café Euro im
Club was hast du schon willst
[Musik]
einfach du als Minion ne letzte Frage
für heute was trinken Sandra Luca häufig
Kölsch wir haben sie das hier in Köln
das ist so aktuell das war Samstag
einfach Samstag krank okay Leute wir
schauen uns mal das Ranking an wenn wir
jetzt nicht auf dem ersten Platz sind
dann weiß ich auch nicht allerdings
würden wir an der Stelle des heutigen
Video jetzt auch beenden wir hoffen es
hat euch gefallen hat
Daumen hoch unter dem Video da abonniert
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
weitere Videos nichts verpassen Luca und
Sandra sind auf der Eins
[Applaus]
[Musik]